che c'è che c'è ecco che c'è vogliamo
cosa rende bene vattene via non ti
voglio più vedere ciao ragazzi benvenuti
ad una puntata di cucina buttata vi
presento il pane da non confondersi con
il pene o con le pinne e sono tante
signore che si chiamano pina il pane
stira che molti pittori scrittori di
fama internazionale ma soprattutto di
cantanti con pezzi quali saf amore amore
[Musica]
sì anch'io
il pane durante più 40 no questa di
figurante momento
[Musica]
allora sei pronto pronto quindi per fare
il pane casa alla gianluigi servono i
seguenti ingredienti giorni giocarmi
l'onore certo farina 500 grammi sale 8
grammi di lievito 5 grammi di olio
extravergine a v.le acqua 370 mm un
cucchiaino di zucchero
marchino che ci fa caso prego già una
buona parola per me non hai capito ti
sei comportato malissimo e adesso lo
facciamo non posso fare nulla sulle mani
legata ci credo quando ormai porti sfiga
ciao mi dispiace allora gianluigi ma che
cosa facciamo per fare il tuo pane
innanzitutto signor panificatore signor
ritengo che siamo gli ingredienti bayern
va lì praticamente durante la quarantena
non si è fatto altro che parificate come
parato scusa a me praticamente mi ha
dato delle dritte il mio amico christian
che so vediamo che salutiamo che c'è un
canale vanificare a casa molto bravo
a pesare quanto
lo dice il tuo amico il mio amico
christian di vanificare a casa che
sentiamo e lasciamo il suo dito qua
sotto anno a questo punto del grande sì
un bacione crei un saluto grazie per la
come ovviamente io faccio un pane del
card oggi ci divertiamo
questo è un po le per tutti poi a
scapito di dieci soprattutto da un pane
che tutti possono fare a key contiamo la
così bravo come è possibile che tutto
questo sia 167 ott
scusate ma questa è una gamma che ci
vuole farci monier e c'è anche un
panificatore professionista mette in
crisi
vogliamo lievito 5 grammi 4 sbaglia
faccio da tanti che si sono stampa jana
ma una bilancia buona questo no non
sento il medico brutto questo 5 era
troppo sciolto troppo ciò ecco ma da 9
euro paesino è un anarchico
non lo diciamo al marchino però che sta
aspettando sotto ragazzina fare scherzi
io gioco con l'ormai più in questa
cucina ma mischia chimica è successo
avuto in tiratura niente rapper q io ho
riportato informata pontico lo splendore
si è licenziato è ultra solo in
quarantena ho fatto tutto quanto
perfettamente arriva gianmarco
all'interno della mia cucina sorridente
molto carino stacco un fallimento ma un
fallimento terribile ma adesso tu sia
condannato chi magari da sotto e prendi
dell'olio mettiamo una seconda casa
che c'è che vuoi ancora qua tre ore che
sono fatte navy a bilanciere una delle
molliche vaffanc un 100 millilitri
d'acqua che non ti puoi sbagliare non
abbiamo altro linea vito bono zucchero
zucchero giù che ho mai fatti le 10
mentre rimescolo qui tu verso chiamato
ancora arrivo subito chi è chi tene via
dicevamo cosa deve fare deve versare la
restante acqua nella farina 270 mi
sembra tra parco adesso che la mia devi
armi scaria finisca a me luce e forza
del palermo è farina del impastare per
mezz'ora quindi ci vediamo per difetto
che però un po di hall e tico tico vai
sotto sopra pulisci tutta la ciotola con
la mano se tu sei una spatola aiuto le
mani finirono su un asfalto
unisci tutto è così
aggiungersi altre ancora certo cioè quel
milione stabili
impastare ancora guardate la consistenza
deve essere tipo un po mito e allora
sarà perfetto
può essere un impasto al 70 è rotto per
cento di 391 non possiamo metterlo nella
planetaria per farlo fare bene bene bene
liscio potremmo mano tutti hanno una
planetaria quindi io direi che si legge
marco marchio italia non entra in acqua
taeg odierna dal 78 dell'uomo è perfetto
dei decreti
adesso creato lo dalle mani perché ce
l'hai detto che dovremmo aspettare un
quarto d'ora che si stabilizzi la maglia
glutin ica come parli terminologie
tecniche mi ha detto christian che io
ovviamente non vedeva le ripeto perché
con la maglia crutin ica scopriamo che
cos'è la maglia glutine ca
la maglia blu ti nico ovvero la rete
magica che fa sollevare gli impasti
fondamentalmente romagna e bruttini che
è una rete magica che fa sollevare gli
impasti pazzesco batti cinque hanno
fatto riposare il nostro in basso si
aggiunge il sale e siti basta col calcio
come suo naturale
andiamo diretti allora l'impastatrice
noi piace ha detto di no mi sento né
journal con la maglia di liga si sta
rinforzando
continuiamo a impastare rendiamo la
bella tosta e ovvio che poi si indurisce
un pochetto uno fa sempre la pietra non
ci va farina no lasciatelo riposare o in
caso tavole aggiungete un po d'acqua
cinque minuti fa ci dobbiamo impastare a
mano non ve lo vedete che cinque minuti
sfiga spingere niente mi volete il mio
vuole rompere il pane e come sta capendo
le pagnotte portata che le vale ci
vediamo fra cinque minuti porta della
consistenza bellissimo ungiamo
leggermente la nostra paul papa ha così
l'impasto non si attaccherà e trova
siamo guardate la maglia glutin ica
guardate che la iss
ma tu sei abbronzato si sta imparando la
farina guardate commovente guarda
guardate quanti veramente pochi
ingredienti della terra non vi
preoccupate è che devi fare una cosa
importantissima stratificare il glutine
con delle pieghe rinforzo a si si si si
fanno tre pieghe bisognerà aspettare
mezz'ora l'una dall'altra ok
la prima è questa dando di sé ma li
prendi da fuori e porti dentro prendi da
fuori o troppo troppo ecco il progetto
giri di 90 e fa la stessa cosa strana lo
so che voglia di farmi
troppo belli lo zio tiro fuori quando
detto venite a vedere così si fa una
piega di forza 16 00 00 è peggio sopra
adesso canavaccio sopra e facciamo
riposare per 30 minuti ma tra poco
momento comunicazioni del parcheggio
armi gen
allora voi a casa ovviamente fatela ogni
mezz'ora rispettate le tempistiche noi
per mancanza di tempo e di voglia
andiamo diretti alla formazione del
panetto che si effettua dopo le 3 pieghe
ci siamo sì non ci sei
sì rieti dell'istruzione e non toccano
il pane vai
eccola chi è stato più lontane messa no
ragazzi avete detto aspetti trasferisci
sopra che è cambiata ma lei ha spiegato
bene cosa devono fare
certo che l'ho spiegato l'avete capito o
no sulla rete camento veloce ora allora
dovete lavorarli il meno possibile
perché sennò si scontrano lasciato che
era troppo di riformare un rettangolo
lungo bravo tira tira destra sinistra
non ci mandare la farina sopra la parte
sopra due terzi e in giù schiaccia tutti
i bordi sinistra sopra esatto destra
bravo 180 no no no no sente lo riceve
a questo va a chiudere tutto bravo
sigilliamo pizzica stiamo formando il
paletto questa ragazzi è una manovra che
va fatta assolutamente soprattutto con
questa felicità
ok quelle che fanno che era vuota di 90
gradi allunga ultimo step lo prendi e lo
comincia ad arrotolare così da e ogni
volta che il rotoli i pollici vanno a
sigillare in questa marco keten di
ramaglie la senti come si sente la
maglia non schiacciare
no però
si no potete vedere adesso un filoncino
in versione precottura pre levitazione
pre maturazione ok lo abbiamo anche un
po attendere sotto lo vedete come si
mette così esatto a ruoti lo vedete che
bello che questo diventerà un filoncino
lievitazione naturale di 12 16 ore una
cosa incredibile ragazzina che lo fanno
canalazzo pulito farina abbondante
all'interno quelle zucchero 2 una volta
messo là dentro andrà inserito nel frigo
per tutta la notte e anche su tutti i
lati perché questo crescerà triplicherà
il volume non gli date retta lo vedete
così tranquillo ne ma in realtà questa
grande questo qui andrà schiacciato sul
fondo manovra delicatissima bravo mamma
andiamo a vederla mastromanno di carlo è
abbondante buonanotte piccolino latte
dolce come lo chiamiamo marcello
marcello marcello l'indomani verrà cotto
bisogna della cosa giorgi stato bravo
perché ieri sera ci ha fatto già
all'impasto quindi a breve marcello pera
stessi tutor da caio
volevo rinunciarci quindi v aspettami
due secondini qui che vado a prendere
cagliari abbiamo preso caso facciamo
vedere cosa è successo durante la notte
lo vedete voteremo la teglia a buy
vl suolo da caraglio pro sorgeranno
girano molto delicatamente no ma no che
sei pazzo tu prendi questo così e poi a
passo mi vorrà sgonfiare caio
c'è una fretta adesso vedete caio del
suo autentico splendore
ok c'è pure qualche pelo una volta
intesa lo accarezziamo per cospargere
bene la farina molto delicatamente a 3
il coc che devo fare taglio aspetta no
no no no aspetta niente dove ci sono mi
chiamano migliore una bella incisione 2
cm fonda io sono molto delicatamente
solitamente ci hanno nella mente i
panettieri alla meta passano papa
guardare il brutto thai mamma lo stemma
o non ci riesce come scusa così sgonfia
gaglio è un minimo di a posto questo è
un taglio ma non riuscito a st basta
ecco un po si sgonfierà ma è normale
adesso in forno crescere toccarlo posso
mettere in forno ci sei
se ci siete se andiamo da forno a stecca
250 dal massimo del forno che ci avete
voi elettrico a gas che si sa guardare
qui c'è un pentolino d'acqua in
ebollizione che ci fungerà da camera di
vapore per il nostro pane in modo tale
che cresce rai non si indurirà sopra che
in cottura 20 minuti così in forno
chiuso al massimo levate il pentolino e
poi continuate la cottura per un quarto
d'ora con il forte
poi schiavo questo strumento con il
coltello con il forte leggermente
iniziamo quindi 20 minuti al massimo
vogliamo ricordare come guglielmo a
cotto testa la ricetta come a stracotto
vorrei dire vediamo sappiamo lo
scopriamo lo scopriamo lo scopriamo no
vabbè è buonissimo
[Musica]
ragazzi noi vogliamo parlarne il profumo
innanzitutto come assurdo adesso a
bermuda andiamo a levare il pentolino da
sotto stando attenti a non bruciarsi lo
vedete non giro sportello con fessurina
e lasciamo dieci minuti un quarto d'ora
non a cuocere a cuore la cuocere adesso
lo asciughiamo asciughiamo lo abbasso
anche la temperatura vado a 200 gradi
non era stato detto questo passiamo a
temperatura ci vediamo fra i dieci
minuti forse anche perché ci siamo ci
siamo ci siamo ci siamo ci siamo
spieghiamo tutto il risultato finale è
un bel filone lievitazione naturale
bellissimo il suono signori microfono
crosta come si deve non c'è trucco non
c'è inganno non c'è un picchio la
finestra siamo noi con il nostro pane
sempre successivo è quello di far
raffreddare il nostro pane onde evitare
che la crosta di 20 gomma io utilizzo
questa maniera andiamo fuori
che bello quello che hanno questa
situazione gravissima quindi mettiamo il
pane in sospensione facciamo passare
l'aria sopra e sotto il pane si taglia
raffreddato no perché c'è un picchio non
c'era un piccola finestra siamo comunque
noi non abbiamo tempo quindi io andrei
col taglio si rifletta la crono lega non
c'è un piccola finestra siamo noi
signore siamo arrivati al momento
dell'assaggio finale come sempre se
volete iscrivetevi a questo canale
metteteci un bel pollice in su per il e
fatemi sapere se avete delle domande dei
consigli e soprattutto
di sapere come chiamereste il vostro
pane detto ciò gianluca peril onore il
pane si è freddato perfettamente andiamo
al taglio signori suono il coltello di
far avanti in diretta è sì ma venite a
vedere più freddo meraviglia guardate
che alberghi guardate che buchi però
vogliamo assaggiarlo anche jean martin e
tiriamo una decina di ragazzi è una cosa
incredibile come crunchy la leggerezza
di stabilità la vogliono vedere grazie a
crea la tua può avere un po di olio sale
andiamo su qui per marco
tieni come ottimo sa perché perché non
c'eri ragazzi ci vediamo la prossima
settimana e grazie già ricci e grazie a
voi